hello grammarians hello rosie hi david
so today we're going to talk about a
special kind of dependent clause which
again is a kind of clause that can't be
a sentence on its own called a relative
clause
so a relative clause is a dependent
clause that starts with a relative
pronoun so okay so a relative pronoun is
a word like
who or that
or which
or whose
or where that like like any pronoun
substitutes in for another part of the
sentence
so for example harry potter is also
known as
the boy who lived the boy who lived
dumbledore
yeah that's my dumbledore i like it
thank you you can see in this
little snippet um
who is subbing in for
the boy
right so so it is behaving like a
pronoun but a relative pronoun and so
we've got this thing here who lived
the boy lived on its own could be a
sentence
but who lived
cannot be
well who lived is is describing the boy
so right now all of this together is
just a noun phrase but who lived within
this noun phrase is a relative clause
so we need to find a store that sells
the new willamette cold brew coffee ice
cream i've heard it's really good
so all of this together is a sentence
this is definitely a sentence we need to
find a store that sells the new
willamette cold brew coffee ice cream
like indisputably that is a sentence we
have our subject we we have a verb need
and then the object of
of need is to find a store that sells
the new willamette cold brew coffee ice
cream
but we're focusing on this yellow part
here
so
that is substituting in for a store
that's what that relative pronoun is
representing
and then we have that sells the new so
we've got store
that sells right so that is our subject
here cells is the verb the new
willamette called coffee ice cream
is the object of cells
and everything in yellow here all this
yellow text is our relative clause it
cannot stand on its own as a sentence
you could not just have
that sells the new willamette cold brew
coffee ice cream
on its own that doesn't work because the
very presence of this
relative pronoun requires more stuff to
go on
let's make things a little bit more
complicated the woman who always wore a
red hat came into the cafe every sunday
so this sentence contains a relative
clause right there in the middle of it
who always wore a red hat
right so we've got who substituting in
for the woman and that's the subject of
the verb phrase wore a red hat
but again this could not be a sentence
on its own now the challenge here is
when you see sentences like this in the
wild and when you see sentences like
these in the exercises they're not going
to be differentiated for your
convenience with two different colors so
you have to be very careful to figure
out
where
this
dependent clause begins and ends so you
can parse so you can make sense of this
sentence in order to make it work so
really this what is this sentence
actually saying just on a base level
the woman came into the cafe
right
and so everything else this every sunday
or who always wore a red hat that is
kind of extra and so it's your job as a
writer reader and editor of text as
someone who is working with the english
language um to puzzle it out
and separate the
sentence into its components
right this is a who always wore a red
hat as a description of the woman right
then we move on to
the
verb the action of the sentence what is
she doing she came into the cafe so
that's
not part of that relative clause the
relative clause is just
in this case
providing some description of the woman
right so use your best sense because
yes it is possible that the red hat
could be the thing that comes into the
cafe every sunday but it's more likely
that that hat is attached to the woman
that was referenced earlier right
so that is a relative clause
you can learn anything david out rosie
out
you